Isadora Duncan --
(Music) --
crazy, long-legged woman
from San Francisco,
got tired of this country,
and she wanted to get out.
Isadora was famous
somewhere around 1908
for putting up a blue curtain,
and she would stand
with her hands over her solar plexus
and she would wait,
and then, she would move.
(Music)
Josh and I and Somi call this piece
"The Red Circle and the Blue Curtain."
Red circle.
Blue curtain.
But,
this is not the beginning
of the 20th century.
This is a morning in Vancouver
in 2015.
(Music)
(Singing)
Come on, Josh!
(Music)
(Singing)
Go!
Are we there yet?
I don't think so.
Hey, yeah!
(Music)
What time is it?
Where are we?
Josh.
Somi.
Bill T.
Josh.
Somi.
Bill T.
(Applause)
Yeah, yeah!